the more you know the more you know you
don't know
Aristotle I love that quote I think that
the world would improve if more people
embrace that and understood that you
know we all think we know everything but
unfortunately that's just not true and
the more people that realize this and
seek truth for themselves will learn
that holy crap
I don't know much at all and I firmly
believe that this whole world would
improve far quicker than we ever thought
possible
if philosophy was taught to children
from the grade school level on up if we
spent less time on crazy math formulas
and I'm not saying we shouldn't teach
math and less time or more time focusing
on teaching people how to be less
materialistic to be less ego driven and
to embrace a more selfish selfless
philosophy like I said the world
unimproved far quicker than what we ever
thought possible
this reminds me and leads me into my
next quote involving communication the
single biggest problem in communication
is the illusion that has taken place
George Bernard Shaw and I would argue
that while communication has always been
and probably always will be humanity's
greatest obstacle that well what we
think at the time and what we say
usually doesn't always well that message
isn't always delivered and it's funny
we're in 2017 we have more abilities in
technical technological capabilities of
communicating than we've ever had and
yet it seems like communication is
getting worse people are they're hearing
but they're not listening they're their
ears are registering a sound but they're
not processing the information they're
receiving they're not considering an
empathetic point of viewer or picturing
themselves the other person shoes for
just a second and to listen and process
what they're trying to tell them and
even we see these issues and text
messaging or emails that you know
someone tries to say something just
right and it just gets taken completely
out of in just the wrong direction we
know this there's so much drama in this
world we've all seen it and like I
mentioned earlier another big problem is
materialism greed it's like we have this
ego driven desire to just accumulate
more things and where our whole society
at least in Western society for that
matter is all about getting the next
best thing
buying things you know look at me look
what I'm wearing look at my purse look
at my car
look at my house in the neighborhood I
live in I'm not saying that buying
things isn't fun and a bad thing at all
but we have gotten to a point most
people I would argue where you know
people have spending addictions people
are always they're not enjoying their
lives like they could and make no
mistake that the desire for materialism
is leading to many people's demise is
pleasing leading to depression and
allowing themselves to slave at work and
this reminds me of a quote by Erich
Fromm greed is a bottomless pit which
exhausts the person in an endless effort
to satisfy the need without ever
reaching satisfaction it's true people
buy things and are always wanting the
next best thing
oh man it's a real big problem and this
read leads me into another quote which
is quite funny by comedian George Carlin
the late comedian George Carlin who
stated trying to be happy by
accumulating possessions is like trying
to satisfy hunger by taping sandwiches
all over your body it's true now in the
title of this video I stated that these
would be thought-provoking
quotes so this one is definitely this
might rub some people the wrong way but
it will get people thinking people
sometimes rationalize their greed by
saying that it is all for the good of
their children but this is nothing but
an excuse they use to make their
despicable actions appear respectable
and praiseworthy Democritus and he said
this a few thousand years ago I mean
that is true I mean it really is so many
people will spend all their time working
and ignore their families which causes
incredible suffering for children and
their upbringing or that people you know
in corporate America and I've seen this
myself or people will step on other
people to get to where they want to be
and it can be very ruthless very
dog-eat-dog a more friendlier way of
putting it is by Joseph Campbell I think
a person who takes a job in order to
live that is to say for the money has
turned himself into a slave work begins
when you don't like what you're doing
there's a wise saying make your hobby
your source of income then there's no
such thing as work and then there's no
such thing as getting tired that's been
my experience I did just what I wanted
to do it takes a little courage at first
because who the hell wants you to do
just what you want to do they've all got
a lot of plans for you but you can make
it happen
Joseph Campbell I am living this
philosophy now I've chosen to become a
professional youtuber I have a Masters
of Business and I
a decided midway through that two-year
program that corporate America was going
to bring me nothing but suffering I was
I was driving myself crazy for my prior
job and it's like so look anything's
possible
get creative we all have creativity and
imagination so whatever your hobby is
whatever you spend hours doing when
you're a kid this is what Joseph Yeow or
excuse me Carl Jung said by the way that
should be what you spend your earthly
time doing you can find ways to make
money doing it a lot of this falls in
line with what Plato said for a man to
conquer himself is the first in noblest
of all victories guys we have so many
desires we have so many ambitions we
allow our egos to get the best of us
I've discussed this a lot in my other
videos about taming the animal that
ultimately we all have issues as a
species the human brain is one hell of a
thing but we're brought into this
environment our society like I said
earlier this is what it thrives on this
is where we're born into so take this
quote from Ralph Waldo Emerson to be
yourself in a world that is constantly
trying to make you something else
is the greatest accomplishment so true
everyone's trying to be just like
everyone else that one's trying to fit
in guys that's crazy it really is crazy
you don't want to be the one that stands
out and you're the weirdo all of a
sudden but man that is that is the
direction of happiness and that reminds
me we in this society you have people
you leave social justice warriors you
see them on TV people that are fighting
for something that they believe in and
in the process they go crazy because
themselves and others so much suffering
and part of the issue and this ties back
to Plato is take what Jordan Peterson
said clean your room what he's referring
to is that we all have problems and
you're not gonna be able to help the
world or other people until you address
your own issues until you look within
fix your problems clean your own damn
room up so to speak which brings me to
Socrates the secret of change is to
focus all of your energy not on fighting
the old but I'm building the new this
worked for a lot of people in fact Steve
Jobs spoke about this people have an
intuitive feeling on what's right what
isn't so spend all of your time building
on what's right as opposed to fighting
the old I mean take for example dr.
Martin Luther King he understood this
darkness cannot drive out darkness only
light can do that hey can I drive out
hate only love can do that and oh my god
did that not work absolutely you know
it's like you look at blacklivesmatter
on these people that just raised
violence and hatred and it's like look
look at what dr. Martin Luther King did
he said that we were only going to love
others no matter how people treat us
what they say to us what we do to us we
are going to embrace them with love and
it worked
did it not he changed the course of
history for the entire country forever
now I just mentioned troof a second ago
so this brings me into my next quote
many people especially ignorant people
want to punish you for speaking the
truth for being correct for being you
never apologize for being correct or for
being years ahead of your time if you're
right and you know it speak your mind
speak your mind even if you are a
minority of one the truth is still the
truth
Mohandas Gandhi that actually leads me
into something that Marcus Cicero said I
have always been of the opinion that
unpopularity earned by doing what is
right is not on popularity at all but
glory
now Liz leads me into my last few quotes
which all have to do with being present
and living in the moment
Pythagoras said the art of living
happily is to live in the present but
he's not the only one that has stayed to
this the future is a concept it doesn't
exist there is no such thing as tomorrow
there never will be
because time is always now that's one of
the things we discover when we stop
talking to ourselves and stop thinking
we find there is only the present only
in internal now Alan Watts which of
course reminds me of Eckhart Tolle a
humans are never fully present in the
now because unconsciously they believe
that the next moment must be more
important than this one but then you
miss your whole life which is never not
now for real I cannot begin to tell you
how much my life has improved once I
started embracing this philosophy of
living in the present moment is true
there is no tomorrow there is no
yesterday yes tomorrow will come
yesterday yesterday happened of course
but it's always right this instant and
we spend so much time thinking about the
future about the past that we drive
ourselves crazy we spend our lives not
enjoying it because you can't enjoy it
when you're lost in your thoughts like
that I know this and it's something you
can practice on believe me I highly
recommend you look into the works of
Eckhart Tolle and Alan Watson and in
fact this leads me into one last quote
and I'm going back to Joseph Campbell
again you are the hero of your own story
Joseph Campbell it's amazing and how
many people have been influenced by this
quote myself included I mean that's
something I'm embracing live your life I
mean guys map out your life on what it
would be if you had to write a story an
adventure story what would it be become
that guy's you know life is short but
you can become anything you're the power
of your intentions and the will to power
cannot be overstated I've discussed this
in other videos embrace this this has
worked for many other people we all have
choices nothing is easy you need courage
but you can do it so anyways guys I'm
Jimmy this is bright insight like and
subscribe leave me a comment and I have
many other videos to come
real soon take care everybody